Dude! That house is giving away
full sized candy bars.
That house forgave my student loan debt.
What the hell kind of street is this?
I'll give you the rest when you retire.
Are you a real woman?
Did you get the student loan thing?
Kind of.
They said the house on the right
made them stop using the front door,
so I had to go to the back door.
Oh.
And I only got 10K
because I don't work
in the public sector.
Well the house on the right gave me an AR15.
Holy crap.
But they made me burned my library card.
Something about drag queens?
That old guy on the left
makes you sit through DEI training
and then takes half your candy
if he thinks you have too much.
Doesn't that guy own like three houses?
Yeah.
And all his candy has stickers
that say “it may cause cancer.”
That guy on the right
took away my Mike and Ike’s.
These things are a slippery slope
to  Three Musketeers.
I've seen a ton of Airheads
and Dum Dums.
On the far left there's a huge
horror show going on.
On the right too but,
those guys are having trouble
with their speaker.
Every new one's the worse than the last!
That red house only gives out candy
if you pass a drug test.
Oh wait, did you get drugs?
Not good ones.
But the one on the far left
gave me hormone blockers.
What about that yellow house with the snake flag
they’re into drugs, right?
It sounds like they were fighting inside.
You don't belong in this house.
It’s not your house, it’s my house!
I have the keys.
You took the keys!
Why is no one giving out drugs?
The news said we’d get drugs.
Maybe people enjoy
taking drugs more than they enjoy
giving them to children.
Did you hit that little pink house?
Somebody did.
All right, just don't go too far left.
The rumor is
they're forcing every kid
to dump out their bags
so they can redistribute
all the candy equally.
Well, that doesn't seem so terrible.
They say the same thing every year
and in the end,
they murder the kids
with too much candy or education,
and eventually everyone starves.
I don't know why kids keep going there.
Well, maybe this year it'll be different?
The kids are always dead by summer.
I bet they just sent those kids to camp.
I mean  you're wrong,
but you're also not wrong.
Oh, yeah. I get it now.
What's your position on abortion?
You can take as many
as there are genders.
Just stick to the middle.
I already got a stimulus check,
sugar subsidies, a sports stadium.
That house even gives you cash
if you promise not to grow any corn!
I heard the Menendez house had gold bars,
but they're not answering
the door anymore.
Oh, hey, it’s that foreign
exchange student.
What's your haul look like, Zelenskyy?
75 billion. But the night is young!
75 billion?
It's how neighborhoods compete now.
It's like a proxy Halloween.